[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNA MIYAJIMA: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much for
joining us here today.
My name is Anna, and
I'm a product manager
working AR Core.
In this session,
we'll be talking
about our faces and
images features,
walking through
some use case ideas,
and then showing you
how you can get started.
AR is all about blending
the physical world
with the virtual.
Last year, we
launched AR Core 1.0,
aiming to help you
build apps that
can understand the
environment and place objects
and information in it.
But to truly blend the
physical and the virtual,
your phone needs to be able
to augment people, places,
and things in a realistic way.
What we're covering
here today is
a set of capabilities AR
Core provides so you can
get started doing just that.
Let's dive right in with faces.
I'll walk us through why
we built Augmented Faces
and what exactly it is.
And then Ranjith, a
tech lead on the team,
will show you how you can
get started with our APIs.
So imagine that you come up with
a brilliant idea for a feature.
And this feature
involves rendering assets
on top of faces.
Building out the algorithms in
order to do this from scratch
is pretty difficult. So you
look around for some options.
You want to make sure that your
feature works at scale on a lot
of different types of phones.
You try out a couple
of the options.
You're not sure if they work
quite the way you need them to.
And you also find that
many cost money to use.
That's why we built
Augmented Faces into AR Core.
Augmented Faces allows you
to have face capabilities
in your own app, works at scale,
and is available at no charge.
And with the improvements
we're announcing here at I/O,
it will work on over
one billion devices.
So what exactly is
Augmented Faces?
Augmented Faces is an API that
provides you with three things.
First, a center pose
for a face, which
marks the middle of a head
and is useful when you want
to do things like render a hat.
Second, region poses,
which are useful when
you want to render assets on
a nose or around the ears.
And last but not
least, a 468 point
dense 3D face mesh
that allows you
to paint detailed textures
that accurately follow a face.
We do all of this,
even the 3D face mesh
without specialized hardware
by using machine learning.
This enables Augmented
Faces to work
at scale, which was
a key requirement we
heard from you, our developers.
We're really excited
about this, especially
because face-based AR unlocks a
wide array of use cases ranging
from beauty and accessory
try-ons to fun face effects
that your users can
enjoy with their friends.
A great example of a developer
that's already started
using Augmented Faces is Meitu.
They're known for their widely
popular photo editing apps that
offer advanced beauty effects.
They've used our 3D face
mesh to create even more
innovative effects, and to speed
up their development process.
The two face effects
that you see here
will be available
next week on Android
in their Beauty Plus app.
If you're physically
here with us at I/O,
another place that you can
try out Augmented Faces
is that our Sandbox.
We've built out this fun
photo booth experience
that you see here.
And what you see is
that we're able to trace
facial features in detail
because of the quality
of our face mesh.
Today we're also excited to
announce that we're bringing
that same face mesh to iOS.
Since the mesh data structure is
the same across both platforms,
you'll be able to create one
asset that runs across both iOS
and Android.
Just like our Android solution,
Augmented Faces on iOS
does not require a depth sensor.
So it will work on
all AR Kit devices.
Combined with our AR
Core certified devices,
Augmented Faces
will run on a total
of over one billion devices.
Ranjith will be joining
me now so we can show you
how this looks on an
iPhone 6S, which is
nearly a four-year-old device.
So this is an effect that Meitu
has built for their Beauty Plus
app using our mesh on iOS.
So what you're
seeing right now is
that as Ranjith turns his
head, the 3D party hat asset is
following his head very well.
And now when Ranjith opens
his mouth, what we get
is a fun little
birthday surprise.
This is just one example of
the delightful experiences
that you can create with AR.
Our iOS APIs will be
available later this summer.
And we can't wait to
see what you build.
Now I'll hand it
over to Ranjith,
who will be diving more
into the technical details.
RANJITH KAGATHI
ANANDA: Thank you Anna.
Hello everyone.
I'm Ranjith Kagathi.
I'm a tech leader
in the AR Corps,
mainly focusing on Augmented
Face as part of the SDK.
In this section,
I'll explain you
what are the building blocks
required to create an Android
app with face effects.
I'll also give you a sneak
peek under the hood, so what
goes on in ARCore to enable
this feature for our developers.
I'll also walk you
through some code snippets
of a sample application that
implements this face effects.
We'll mainly discuss
about two face effects.
One on the left there
is a couple of fox ears
and a nose attached somewhat
rigidly to the face.
So when the head
moves, turns, rotates,
you'll see that the virtual
content moves along with it.
On the right side
there is a face paint
overlayed on top of the face.
And this not only moves
when the head moves,
but it also
stretches and expands
as the person opens the mouth,
makes some facial expressions
and gestures.
What are all the
building blocks required?
We need virtual container,
we need real images
with human faces, and we
need metadata about the face,
as in where the face is
looking at, how is it oriented?
And what are the
attachment points
on the face where we can
attach this virtual content?
We also need a way to
blend all these together
into a composite image that
you can show it to the user.
But don't worry.
You don't have to build
all these blocks yourself.
We will provide SDKs
to make it easier
for you to develop such an app.
As an app developer,
you'll be mostly
responsible on creating
the experiences to create
the virtual content.
In ARCore we
configure and control
camera to provide good quality
images for this use case.
The ARCore also
processes these images
to output metadata information.
In this case a region
pose, one on the nose
and two on the-- either
side of the forehead.
And also we provide a center
pose, a [INAUDIBLE] information
in the form of pose.
We also provide you
a scene from SDK.
This makes it straightforward
to render realistic 3D scenes
in both AR and non-AR
cases without having
to go through the complex
case of low-level open GL API.
This is one rendering approach
to render these effects.
You could as well use
Unity or Unreal engines
if you are interested in so.
Augmented faces supports both
Unity and Unreal on Android.
Similarly, if you are
interested in developing a face
mask or a face tattoo we
provide you a dense 3D face
mesh onto which you can overlay
the texture information.
The face mesh is
designed in such a way
that more vertices are assigned
to the parts of the face which
had a feature-rich like lips,
eyes, and just off the nose.
And vertices are
sparsely distributed
on less feature-rich areas
like foreheads and chin.
So each of the
vertex will provide
a x, y, z, the coordinates,
and also give you
a u and v texture coordinate
for associating a texture.
We also give you a
three-axis normals
that you could use it
to apply any lighting
effects on the face, or even
to smooth out the face effect.
In summary the ARCore provides
region poses and face mesh.
App developer creates
the virtual content.
And we have scene form Unity
and Unreal to combine all these
into a composite image.
How does it all work?
How is ARCore able to provide
a 3D face mesh from a 2D image
without any depth hardware?
We use machine
learning models that
are built on top of TensorFlow
Lite platform to achieve this.
And the crossing
pipeline is optimized
to run on device in real time.
We use a technique
called transfer
learning wherein we train
the neural network for two
objectives, one, to
predict 3D vertices
and to predict 2D contours.
To predict 3D vertices, we train
it with synthetic 3D data set,
and use this neural
network as a starting point
for the next stage of training.
In this next stage, we
use annotated data set,
annotated real world data set to
train the model for 2D contour
prediction.
The resulting network not
only predicts 3D vertices
from a synthetic data
set, but can also
perform well from 2D images.
We want to make sure the
solution works for everyone.
So we train the network with
geographically diverse data
sets so that it works
for all types of faces,
wider faces, taller faces,
and all types of skin colors.
So we have 3D face mesh.
But where do we really need
to really 3D face mesh?
Take a look at this picture
of my colleague Lewis.
What's special about this image
is Lewis does not wear glasses.
So what you see there
is virtual glasses.
And see how accurately
it tracks the face?
Even the sides of
the glasses frame
tracks the head
movement very well.
It looks so realistic, I have to
cycle through different colors
to convey that it is indeed
virtual glass and not real.
Now let me freeze the video when
the face is an extreme angle.
Notice how a part of the virtual
glasses is behind the nose.
To achieve this,
you need to have
3D information about the face,
that very space between nose
and the cheek where
you can actually
render the virtual image.
So this is what ARCore provides.
And to enable these complex
algorithms on mobile devices,
we have multiple
adaptive algorithms
built into the ARCore.
These algorithms sense
dynamically how much time
it has taken to process
previous images,
and adjust accordingly various
parameters of the pipeline.
We use multiple ML
models, one optimized
for higher quality
and one optimized
for higher performance when
the compute resources are
really challenging.
We also adjust
pipeline parameters
such as inference rates so
that we skip a few images,
and instead replace that
with interpolation data.
With all these
techniques, what you get
is a full frame rate
experience for your user.
So we provide face mesh and
region poses at full camera
frame rate, while handling
all these techniques internal
to the ARCore.
With this background, we
are now ready to build
the app in three steps.
Step one, create
virtual content,
step two, configure ARCore,
step three, configure scene form
or other rendering
engines to build your app.
To create virtual content, we
provide economical face mesh
in an FBX file
format in our SDK.
So you don't load the
FBX file, import it
into your 3D
software, and create
your own virtual content.
Or you could even reuse
your existing content
and attach it to the
canonical face mesh.
So this is the step that
decides which parts of the face
should control
what virtual asset.
Similarly, to build
2D texture content,
we provide a template texture.
We listened to you developers.
Recently when, we
launched Augmented Faces,
developers expressed
interest that they
want to know which vertices
corresponds to what
parts of the face.
So in our latest
SDKs, we are going
to include this
template texture, which
is a flattened version
of the face mesh.
And various regions
of the face is being
marked with these guidelines.
You import this template
texture as a layer in your image
editing software and apply
your own face paint effect
as another layer on top of it.
You can adjust where the tattoo
or a face paint should appear.
And you export it as a PNG file
by hiding the template texture
and only exporting the
content you created.
Now that we have
virtual content,
it's time to write code and
use that virtual content.
First, we will
configure the ARCore.
The ARCore by
default is configured
to run plane finding on
a rear-facing cameras.
We will [INAUDIBLE]
the configuration
using this step to configure
it for front camera
and to output 3D face mesh.
This is an indication
to the ARCore
that it should run the
model inferences to generate
face mesh every frame.
Now let's move to
the step three.
In your main app activity
in onCreate method,
import the virtual
content you created.
This is a scene from construct
to load 3D Contain into scene
form.
I'm making an assumption here
that you already imported this
into Android Studio.
And the resources available
in resources folder.
Similarly, you can import
the 2D texture you design
into the same form using
the texture builder.
Now let's create a listener
that listens to the updates
from ARCore every frame.
As I mentioned,
Augmented Faces provides
information about vertices.
Vertices include texture
coordinates, x, y,
z components, and normals,
as well as region poses.
But you don't have to work with
all these components yourself.
This is where the new
additions to scene form
comes from, where it supports
natively Augmented Face node.
So you'll create the
Augmented Face node
off scene form using the
ARCore's Augmented Faces API.
Now the number of lines
of coding you are to do
is very few.
On such a face node, you set
3D asset under 2D texture.
And that's it.
With three simple steps, ta-da!
You have a Android
app with face effects.
So everything we discuss now
is already available on Android
on our developer page.
You can download the
SDK and build your apps.
This was about Augmented Faces.
Now I will hand
it over to Ashish
to talk about Augmented Images.
ASHISH SHAH: Thank you, Ranjith.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Ranjith.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm glad so many of you
could join us today.
My name is Ashish.
I'm a product manager at Google.
And I work on a ARCore.
I'll be specifically talking
about Augmented Images.
For the next 15 to
20 minutes, we're
going to go through four topics.
The first one is the rationale
behind Augmented Images.
Why did we design
Augmented Images?
What's it good for?
Number two, we will talk about
how Augmented Images works.
And we're going to
specifically talk about
this in the context of two apps
that we are showcasing here
at I/O. Number three, we
will talk about a few updates
that we are doing, a few
significant updates that we
are doing to ARCore as
part of the ARCore launch
to Augmented Images as
part of the ARCore launch.
And lastly, we to talk about
how do you, as developers, take
all of this and put Augmented
Images into your own app?
So let's start.
Why Augmented Images
in the first place?
So today, people frequently
interact with physical images,
whether they are
at a store, they're
looking at some product,
reading the product signage
to understand more
about the product.
Or they could be
at a movie theater
and they could be
looking at a movie poster
to learn more about the movie.
Or they could be at a
venue like Google I/O
where it's actually loud
and they're kind of lost.
And they're looking at
a map, a physical map,
to figure out where they are.
Our goal with
Augmented Images is
to take these
interactions that people
have with physical images and
make them a lot more engaging
and make them a lot more useful
to the users and context.
We're showcasing one
such example here
at the Sandbox right
across this corner.
Here, users would
be able to scan
product signage, in this
case, of an espresso machine.
And as soon as they scan
the product signage,
you would see 3D overlays
of product features
right on top of the object.
This is a super powerful
way for manufacturers
of these appliances to convey
their product benefits,
to convey their product
features in a way
that they could otherwise not
do with just plain 2D text or 2D
signage.
And as I had mentioned
earlier, the most powerfully
our experiences are the ones
that are able to take the real
and take the physical and blend
them together realistically.
This is an example where you're
able to take virtual content
and blend it on
top of a real world
object in the right context.
So how does Augmented
Images work?
Let's take a look.
At a high level, Augmented
Images does three things.
The first one is it's able
to recognize a pre-registered
image.
So in this case of the espresso
machine demo that we just
talked about, the app developer
has registered the signage
as an augmented
image inside the app.
Second, when the users
scan the augmented image,
Augmented Images will
give you a six degrees
of freedom pose of the image
with respect to the image.
What does that mean?
So for example, if this was
the image and this is a device,
once I'm done scanning
my image, what
it tells me is the position
of my device with respect
to the image in
x, in y, and in z.
It also tells me the orientation
with respect to the image
in pitch, yaw and roll.
So with these six numbers, the
x, y, and z, and the pitch,
yaw, roll, you are
able to describe
the position and orientation
of the device or the image
accurately.
And this is what allows you
to go to the third step, which
is to take this information
and augment 3D content on top
of it.
And when you augment 3D
content on top of the image
or offset with the
image, the content
would stay there, regardless of
how you move it on your device.
And that creates this illusion
of the virtual content
being stuck to the real world.
So as you might have heard
from Sundar during the keynote,
we've launched this experience
called Explore I/O as part
of the I/O 2019 app.
This allows the attendees to
go and scan physical signage
that you might have seen around.
And as soon as you
scan physical signage,
you are able to see what's
around the signage in terms
of landmarks.
So where is the nearest Sandbox
for demos or where are the code
labs?
You should be able to just
pan your camera on your phone
and be able to see that.
Let's deconstruct
this experience
to figure out how
Augmented Images is
being leveraged in here
to power this experience.
The first thing
we have is that we
have 50 such unique
signposts which
are placed at very, very precise
locations all across the Google
I/O venue.
And you have these
landmarks-- just because we've
designed a venue, we know where
exactly each of these landmarks
are with respect
to the signposts.
For example, I know that there
are signposts right outside.
And the session stage
number six is right here.
So the signposts
and the landmarks
maintain a common
frame of reference.
Now when a user goes ahead
and scans a signpost,
what Augmented Images
does it provide the six
degrees of freedom pose
of the device with respect
to the augmented image.
So now you combine the position
of the device with respect
to the image and the
information about the landmarks
with respect to
the image, and what
you have is the information
about where the landmarks are
with respect to the device.
This is what allows you to
overlay content right on top
of the physical world.
And as you move
your device around,
you are able to see this
content stay in place.
We are also excited to announce
several significant updates
to Augmented Images as part
of the ARCore release I/O.
And a lot of this has been
in response to feedback
that we heard from
you developers.
If you had a couple of
algorithmic improvements
under the hood, which lead
to much higher tracking
precision and much
higher detection recall.
What does that mean
for developers?
So when you start
anchoring virtual content
on top of real physical
objects, that's
when your margin of error,
in terms of how much can
the content shift around
while you are tracking.
The margin of error that
is actually super small.
And so the improvements
that we made
in the past several
quarters will
allow you to now start
annotating real world
physical objects, and give your
users an illusion that it's
actually there.
We also now allow you
to track multiple images
in the scene, not
just one image,
but multiple images
in the scene.
And lastly-- this part
I'm most excited about--
is the ability to track images
that are not static, but can
move around.
And we continue to track them.
Let's look at that for a bit.
In previously ARCore
versions, ARCore
used to give you back a
pose of the image at 2
Hertz, so roughly every
two times a second.
And that means that if the
image was to move around
while the session is
going on, it is possible
that the virtual content would
lag because the images are not
being tracked continuously.
So what we have done
is now the image poses
are being given at 30 Hertz.
So we've increased the
frequency at which we give you
updates by 15x, but
at the same time,
we made sure that the power
consumption does not rise.
So the overall power consumption
rises by less than 3%
for a 15x increase in the
frequency of the poses that
deployed.
And we also realize that
as your images move around,
they might go out of your
camera field of view.
And with the higher
detection recall,
we're able to help
with that as well.
And we're excited with what
some of our early developers
are doing with moving
augmented images.
JD.com is an e-commerce company.
And they've come up with
an app called JD AR Books.
This is an educational app
for really young children
that teaches them how to
spell simple English words.
So as you scan a letter C, you
would see an augmentation come
up on top of letter
C. And as you move C,
the augmentation
moves along with it.
And it's only when you place
all the three letters together
that an achievement is
unlocked and you actually
see a virtual car in this case.
If you were to
misplace the letters,
you would actually not
see that happening.
As you've seen in
most of these examples
so far, what we have
done in ARCore core
is take the real world and add
more information on top of it.
But ARCore can
also do more things
in terms of being able
to make you visualize
the world in a different
way, not just add new stuff,
but be able to visualize
it in a different way.
So if you know US
currency traditionally
does not feature faces of women.
Most of the faces on US currency
is today of prominent men.
A former US
Treasurer, Rosie Rios
has partnered with the
Google Creative Lab,
they've created this AR
experience call Notable Women.
This allows users
to take US currency
and be able to replace
the faces on US currency
with the faces of women who have
made a tremendous impact on US.
And this helps people learn more
about these remarkable women.
Hopefully, all of these
examples have sparked some ideas
in terms of what all you can
do with Augmented Images.
Now we'll spend the
next few minutes
talking about how do you
actually take Augmented Images
and put it as part
of your own app.
There are three
steps at a high level
to create an
Augmented Images app.
The first one is to create a
database of images that will be
used to trigger the experience.
Number two, is to create and
configure an ARCore session
to use Augmented Images.
And finally, at runtime,
you query the camera
at every frame at 30
Hertz and figure out
what is a pose of the
image that you are tracking
and render content on top of it.
Let's go through
each of these steps.
Here in the first step, you'll
identify all the set of images
that you would want to
trigger experiences of.
Today we allow you to create a
database of up to 1,000 images,
1,000 unique images that your
users can scan and trigger
your experience.
We provide you an
offline tool that you can
use to generate this database.
We also provide you a way to
do this at runtime in your app
as well.
For the purpose of
the code snippets that
are going to follow,
we're going to assume
that an Augmented Images
database has already
been created offline.
The second thing
with any ARCore app
is to create and configure
any ARCore session
to do a particular thing.
As Ranjith did so in the
case of Augmented Faces,
we'll do so now in the
case of Augmented Images.
You create an ARCore session.
And then you take this
Augmented Image database
that you had created earlier.
You decode it,
and you pass along
the decoded database
as a parameter
and do ARCore config session.
With these simple
code lines, you
should be able to create and
configure an ARCore session.
Then you move along
to at runtime.
What you do is
you start creating
the pose of all these
images that you are
tracking at every camera frame.
And what ARCore
would return back
is the pose of
each of the images
and the tracking status
of each of these images,
whether or not it's
tracking or not
tracking the image might
have gone out of view.
So it will give you
a status update.
And as long as the
images are tracking,
you can go ahead and render
physical content right
on top of these images.
So in these three
simple steps, you
should be able to create a
basic Augmented Images app.
But we'd like you
to go a bit further.
There are certain things
that we have learned
from experimenting with this.
And we call them
our best practices.
As you know, the
Augmented Images database
lives and dies by the
quality of the images
that you'll be
tracking or scanning.
It is very important that
you choose images that
are great for your experience.
And we provide you a
tool that will tell you
if your image is
good or bad in terms
of a score for an Augmented
Images experience.
So what are the images
that qualify as good images
and will give you a great score?
The first one is images that
avoid heavy compression.
We don't want heavily
pixilated images.
You also want to choose images
that have at least a 300
by 300 resolution.
And lastly, you want
to choose images
which have distinct
non-repetitive features.
The last point is a bit subtle
and it's lost a lot of times.
We've got a couple
of examples in here.
Here you see on
the left hand side,
you see this image of a globe.
If you see this
globe, there are lots
of distinct high, contrast
patterns on this image.
And there's nothing that
repeats across the image.
So it's a really good image
to track and to recognize
as an augmented image.
But the image on the right hand
side, the one of the building,
it has lots of features.
But once you actually
start scanning the image,
you understand that there are
these lots of repeating windows
that go across the image.
And so it is very easy for
the algorithms under the hood
to get confused as to
what they are looking at.
And so such an image
would not be idealy suited
for an Augmented
Images experience.
And our tool will tell you
that the score of this image
is super low.
So if we would highly encourage
that you choose images
that are closer to the ones
that give you a score of 100.
Also another important step
is how do you onboard users?
AR is a very, very new
interactive experience
for most people.
And it is important
that you teach users
how to be successful
in the experience.
The first step in an
Augmented Images experience
is for the user
to scan an image.
So how do you tell
a user that hey, you
are supposed to scan an image
you start the experience.
A couple of visual
cues will help.
In our case, we tend
to use these brackets.
These virtual
brackets that show up
on your camera field of view.
And these steer the users
towards scanning the image.
A simple text can also help.
We've seen that if you do
either of these things,
we've seen a remarkable
uptick in the success ratio
in terms of how users
perceive your app.
You also want to make sure
that the users are not just
scanning tiny images.
They get closer if
the images are small.
So make sure you size the
brackets appropriately so
users are putting in
the images at least 25%
of the screen space.
With these code lines
and best practices,
you should be able to create
a really good Augmented Images
app.
And we'd love to know what
you'd be up to with this.
And we are here to help.
As part of I/O, we
have several codelabs.
Augmented Faces has
its own codelab.
So does Augmented Images.
In less than 30
to 45 minutes, you
should be able to create
your first Augmented Image
or Augmented Face app.
There's also a Sandbox demo if
you're looking for inspiration
on what could AR do.
There's a Sandbox, which is
right across the street here.
And or dev site,
developers.google.com/AR has
latest and the most up to
date information on our APIs
and on our SDK.
And as for us, myself,
Ranjith, and Anna,
we'll stick around after
the presentation is done.
If you folks have any questions
on the code that we presented,
if you have questions
on use cases,
or if you're looking
for more features
and have questions on that,
we'd love to hear from you.
So please stop by.
We'll hang around right here.
Thank you again
all for joining us.
We really appreciate
it, and hope you all
have productive I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]